[Music]
all right to switch presentations right
all right so I am it's correct he's
right I am the president of our studio
I'm usually the shiny-headed guy you see
in some people's photos like when they
take photos with Hadley and you see
there's a bald shiny-headed guy next to
him that's usually me and they're like
why is this guy keeps showing up in
these photos if you attended my talk
last year at our studio Kampf
you know that I am regrettably not a
data scientist contrary to what Hadley
said yet one of these days I will get
there
I do enjoy playing with our I found I
find it you're my background is in
software engineering and mathematics but
I love to play with art and I love to
explore how you can use it to understand
the world more deeply and hopefully make
better data-driven decisions it is
precisely the question of understanding
the world and making better data drew
service bethe driven decisions this is
gonna be so easy for me I can tell you
know it's funny of my I was talking
about wife and my seven year old said
you know the would that get fired if he
screws up on this presentation I said I
don't think I will be fired for this but
all right
so six years ago I got into our and
eventually I met JJ and at a time I
didn't fully understand or appreciate
just how incredible the our community
was and continues to be and the positive
impact you all have on this world I also
hadn't gotten a full picture of what was
possible with this remarkable tool chain
you're here a lot from Pete speakers
this week about the power of the open
source packages that are created in our
and I don't need to tell you guys about
all the incredible things that that are
sort of coming down the pike my goal in
this talk is to actually give you a
deeper look at our studio story what we
believe in and how organizations have
adopted our and the our ecosystem to
solve real world problems so given the
rate of innovation change it is often
difficult to stay on top of what is
possible and how the puzzle pieces fit
together I happen to know this because
last year I was lucky enough to visit 30
different customers all over the world
and my goal was to sort of talk to them
about the new products we're building
where we're going and to see whether the
problems that we're solving are the same
problems that they are trying to solve
for themselves and it became really
obvious that most people have don't have
the full story and it's really hard
occurred to me that the really reason
for that is because we've never told
that story publicly so let's let's make
sure that you guys walk out of here with
three things today what is the way of
our studio right what do we believe in
why do we do the work that we do
how can you adopt our in production and
finally how does our sustain itself
you'd be surprised how many people still
ask me that question to answer that I'm
gonna take you back to 1439 does anybody
know what was created in 1439 what was
invented the printing press I knew
somebody in the audience would know the
answer to that question so it wasn't so
hard about the time there's a goldsmith
by the name of Johannes Gutenberg right
and he invented the movable type based
printing press prior to its arrival the
process for creating content was one
where people would write manuscripts
usually monks Rick isn't they're the
only ones that could read and write and
the process was really really slow and
very expensive which meant that
knowledge gets centralized into the
hands of the few and being able to
validate the authenticity and
correctness of the work was really
really difficult having a press that
could accelerate the creation of perfect
fidelity copies of a book most notably
the good book at the time radically
changed who could have access to
knowledge and increase the confidence
that everybody was seeing the same
information
many believe and including Wikipedia
that the arrival of the printing press
helps start and fuel the Scientific
Revolution in the 16th century I'm
particularly attracted this few concepts
in here about you know in Austria in the
era of mass communication permanently
altering the structure of society now
500 years later we have the prime
directive John Chambers wrote about this
in his book and I think it's so
important and it captures who we are and
what we do so well that it bears reading
out loud science business in many other
areas of society continually rely on
understanding data and the and that and
that understanding frequently involves
large and complicated data processes
those who receive the results of modern
data analysis
have limited opportunity to verify the
results by direct observation users of
the analysis have no option but to trust
the analysis and by extension the
software that produced it
this place is an obligation on all
creators of software to program in such
a way that the computations can be
understood and trusted this obligation I
label the prime directive so for us code
is reproducibility reproducibility is
good science if you believe in code and
reproducibility you can get reuse you
can get automation you can get
scheduling you can get parameterization
good science for us is good business so
I don't rush about this over this too
quickly what we are saying here if you
can reproduce your analysis you can
recreate it you can repeat it and in the
same context or a new one and you can
always reproduce your analysis if you
record your analysis in code so last
November I was at a conference in
Barcelona the Gartner conference and
there was this big movement that was
starting up called the no code movement
I don't know how many of you guys are
familiar with it but I sat there and I
listened to what what folks were saying
and I saw the CIOs who sort of like this
is really exciting this is gonna be the
new world I don't have to hire data
scientist I don't have to code you know
and it occurred to me that we are
basically the opposite I'm like why did
I show up to the show so I figured it
would be good to just remind people of
what we believe there are four things
with four reasons that we love code
right the repeatability I suspect
everybody here would agree with right
it's important for your analysis to be
repeatable and reproducible down the
road it's one of the key tenants if you
will of the scientific process but there
are other elements that are also
important in spectable analysis so
inspectable analysis speaks to the
ability to review the work point out
flaws and the assumptions or suggest
improvements it ultimately helps one
understand how the results were achieved
in a transparent manner reusable
analysis addresses the ability to
leverage that same work again for future
work or to build on
extended if you want to solve something
new
you might Google for it and understand
that someone has done what someone's
done to solve the same or similar
problem it serves as a foundation for
sharing and then finally difficult
analysis I tried this out a feud for a
couple of days and most people I don't
know what difficult analysis is and so
this may seem like a variant of inspect
ability but it is important it's an
important in its own right what we're
talking about with difficult ook
impaired the changes made to your
analysis over time or somebody else's
analysis over time it makes it easier
for you understand why decisions were
made and if there were mistakes where
the errors were introduced along the way
so for us ultimately we believe complex
problems will require code code is
communication communications critical
communications what gives you then
leverage right single data scientists
creates something that a whole bunch of
other people in the organization can use
to solve real problems with code you can
inspect how a problem is solved and
either adopt it or figure out how to
improve it yourself and finally with
code the answer is always yes all right
so oh shoot this is not my last
presentation it's Japan I spent all this
time getting this nice nice little
animation in place that shows you guys
all the variants packages so this is the
final result
174 packages that we that we maintain in
support for the art community and we're
excited that over 50% of our engineering
team works on free and open source
software and our company is more than
50% engineering so just because you have
really fantastic open-source tools
doesn't mean that you can get them into
your production environments or you can
get your company to adopt them right it
turns out that there are multiple
constituencies that you have to deal
with right so data scientist is one of
them business users are another and IT
admins or your DevOps or your data
engineers there's a whole bunch of a
whole class of folks that have a vested
interest in how you operate and how you
use your your data in production and so
everybody has a set of their have their
own set of activities and they
their own set of concerns that they that
they need to worry about so what we've
been trying to do is figure out how to
make that easier how to get that
adoption to happen into the organization
how do you get people to move from a
world where they have a lot of point and
click drag and drop solutions to one
that sort of grounded in code and to
that what we've done is added our
commercial products right and if you
take a look our commercial products are
meant to address all of those concerns
on the right hand side right so I
mentioned that I'm going to show you
some of the things that we talked about
with with customers over the last year
and I'm gonna introduce I'm going to go
back to sort of the IDE and sir and if
you guys can go back in time and think
six seven years ago most people were
using the IDE on a desktop right some
organizations started using our studio
server to help centralize the workloads
and better manage capacity and access to
the data but six years ago we started
hearing feedback from the IT teams
within organizations and they were being
asked to help support the growing use of
our in their organization they asked for
features around some but they wanted to
be able to better control access to
resources they wanted to be able to
audit the usage they wanted high
availability they wanted multiple
versions of our they wanted the ability
to start multiple sessions collaborative
editing etc right so we added all these
these capabilities into our premium
product line and that has Trey has
helped us get over a thousand enterprise
customers today in the past two years
we've seen IT organizations experiment
with the use of docker and some have
even started playing with distributed
computing platforms the pattern they use
is to bake our studio server and shiny
server directly within a docker
container so that each session would run
a full server process we've been working
on a refactoring of professional
products to change the execution model
which we are calling the launcher in
this new model we've separated the
execution of the r-process
from the server that is responding to
the user this will allow customers to
start an our process on a remote machine
so this is let's actually take a look
and see what this looks like oh shoot I
forgot oh so
that's weird that it got that at the
heart of all of our work is our art art
are our packages right so again for us
everything starts from the are the open
source and and expands out so let start
with the IDE this is I'm gonna start a
new session and in this session it
happens to be using kubernetes I'll name
the session I'll be able to control the
CPU resources that are used the memory
that is used in the base image that I'm
that I'm leveraging and once I start the
session I should be I should get an IDE
that looks identical to what you guys
see on your desktops today not all that
impressive but if you run the plot I
should be able to see that the work and
now I can dig into I can go to the
kubernetes dashboard and take a look and
see the jobs that are running this is an
hour process that's running inside of a
kubernetes contained inside of docker
container on kubernetes and you can see
that it has the same metadata that I
entered in the previous report now going
back to the IDE
I can go ahead and take this ID this
session has started with that users
context in the right with the right
level of permissions so if I go back to
the packages I can go ahead and take a
look and see this particular base image
does not have all of the you know it has
a very limited set of packages and if I
search for shiny you'll notice that
Chinese not in there if I want to go
ahead and start a new session this time
maybe a validated environment so the
organization says okay there's a set of
packages that I'm okay with you guys
using their pre-configured they can bake
that into another base image that that
has those particular packages in them I
go ahead and start that project and
[Music]
here if I search for SHINee you'll see
that the SHINee package is there now
this comes from a package manager the
pannu plat product that we introduced in
October called the our studio package
manager and the our studio package
manager was created to help the IT team
be able to manage what versions of
packages you have in production right so
you can create different repos each of
these repos can have a subset of
packages that have been approved by
somebody if you want them if you want
them to and then any AR process that is
pointing to that particular repo will be
able to get exactly the same versions of
the R package so this is speaking again
to the getting a reproducible version of
the R code that you're using so the Art
Studio package manager was was starting
these IT organizations because one of
the key problems that we've seen is that
there's there's a big spectrum of usage
of R in product in in in these
organizations so some people have a Wild
West model you can use any package that
you want anywhere enough obviously
there's a there's a concern here about
reproducibility right unless you're
using something like pack wrap others
lock down there are packages so that you
can only use what has been pre-approved
and blessed and and that's sort of a
very draconian process you have to get
special approvals to get through what
we've done with our studio package
managers made it easier for you to be
able to cater to either end of the
spectrum so on one side of the spectrum
you may say I want my Rd team to be able
to have access the latest and greatest
version of anything you know and crayon
or any of our internal packages but on
the other side you could say you know
what when we get closer to production
environments or if we want to go to a
validate environment this is a
pre-selected set of work that the set of
packages that you can use and define and
so that hopefully will make it radically
easier for organizations to be able to
sit manage this so one of the things
that you will notice that we've invested
quite a bit of timeline is trying to
solve the problem for IT organizations
who honestly don't know anything about
our right they're being asked they have
a lot of demands there's a lot of new
technology that they have to work with
and we want to make it much easier for
them to use our in production
so enough about package management let's
switch to something that everybody here
is more comfortable with shiny here's a
shiny application that happens to show
you a stock portfolio over time and as
you can see this stock portfolio is
indicating that the markets not doing so
well hopefully most of you guys have
noticed that but what's powerful about
shiny is that you are York you can give
people the ability to interact and
explore questions and get the answers
for themselves so in for the sake of the
example let's say I'm I'm showing up in
a meeting and I have a bunch of
stakeholders I pull up this application
and we see something that is interesting
to us right and people say oh that's so
that looks fantastic how do I get this
particular report how do I get a report
of this on a weekly basis right and
again what's nice here is that this
shiny application has all the code that
it took to run it and so in theory it's
completely reproducible I can hand it to
somebody else and when they run it they
are running exactly the same code that
you created but so they say okay I want
this on a weekly basis or somebody else
and some other stakeholders you know
that's nice I want a slightly different
set of variables but I want that on a
monthly basis or a quarterly basis so
what do you do when that happens and so
what we're proposing is that you take a
look at our markdown and our markdown so
here's here's an our markdown doc that
has the same logic and visualizations
that you saw in the shiny application
but an our markdown if you haven't seen
it is a text-based literate programming
content format that allows you to mix
prose code and output into a single
document you can even use latex
equations so those you know so similar
notebooks you can have the outputs in
line but one of the key powers is that
you can reproducibly knit the document
into a variety of output formats for
those of you who heard my talk last year
you know that I use our markdown with IO
slides to create our quarterly board
deck in this example we'll use PDF so if
you take a look at this this is exactly
the same set of visualizations and data
that we saw in the in the shiny
application once I'm happy with this I
can decide to go ahead and
save save my work and how do I say that
I'm gonna go ahead and check it in when
we go to check it in this is when we
talk about the difficult Ori this is
what we're talking about right I can
actually go ahead and see the exact
changes that were introduced and and and
and and this gives me the ultimate
transparency in in how much that this is
so easy the transparency is making much
easier for me to review the spread than
in any spreadsheet or any
point-and-click solution once I have
what I want once I've done with it I go
and go ahead and publish this to and
share with other people and what I'm
proposing here is that you publish it to
connect because connect is actually the
easiest way for you to publish your data
products to your organization the pub
Connect will actually go ahead and
detect all the dependencies and and push
up the full code up to the server so you
can go ahead and and the server now can
go ahead and recreate that analysis
within a secure sandboxed environment
right same PDF report that we were
looking at earlier now what's nice about
Connect is because all the data is up
there I can go ahead and rerun that
analysis at any moment in time I can
also control who has access to this
analysis right I can say okay everybody
in the company can see it so only some
people can see it I can also email the
report out and this particular report is
cussing allows you through code to
customize the the subject line the body
of the email including the various
graphs that we had and the attachments
that are included so the attachments
here are not only the PDF doc that we
looked at earlier but actually any
content that you created
programmatically in the our markdown doc
so in this case we have both the CSV
file and we have the PowerPoint is the
PowerPoint presentation that you may
decide if you look at it's okay this is
really great I'm gonna go ahead and send
that to to my boss right to my exec the
other elements that I did not get a
chance to show you here is with our
markdown but the fact that we just did
this with our markdown you have complete
reproducibility of the work that you've
done one of the other elements we have
not shown you is sort of the
parameterization of our markdown Docs so
you can take that same report that I
showed you earlier and and expose the
same kind of input parameters that you
saw in SHINee but then allow the users
to go ahead and interact with them and
for each of these parametrized versions
you can go ahead and send that out to
your constituency so your consider we
can look at it say okay I really like
the aggressive version of the portfolio
and so I want to be able to receive that
on a weekly basis because that really
matters to me whereas on for other for
other members of the organization say I
want to get this on a quarterly basis I
don't care you know I have a longer-term
view in terms of how i think about
portfolios and so i will go ahead and
pull that in so this is one of the key
tenets that we see if you thought about
the printing press this is a way for you
to sort of recreate the printing but all
through code next thing that we talk
about a lot about is that you know
connect our studio server pro and con
package manager make make it easier for
you to put our they are into production
now most organizations they don't have
just our users right they have a variety
of tools and services and connections
and that they need to be op interoperate
with and so the next thing I want to
spend time on is showing you that sort
of the next superpower of our our as a
glue language right many of you guys may
have experienced that firsthand
so we'll start by showing how you can
connect our two spark since spark is
still the new hotness I think and in the
IDE this is available in the open-source
version you can connect to a spark
cluster and for those of you have never
seen this I can create a notebook from
it pull it back into the our markdown
doc and now I can start writing deploy
our code that I'm familiar with and
what's really powerful about this is
that even though I'm writing the are
what looks like regular deep layer code
that runs in our when this this code
looks to run it's actually running in
spark and so well let's take a look and
see what that looks like here's the
spark a sequel that this would actually
run at that moment in time and if I go
ahead and change that code I can go
ahead and run it so that I can get the
data back I can get the summary data
back so
could be working on a data set that is
very very large and and similarly I can
be I can leverage any of the machine
learning algorithms that are in spar
again this is leveraging the sparkly are
open-source package you guys can play
with it if you're interested the next
thing that we've sort of invested is
eventually more time and is on
connecting to databases so some of you
guys may have seen this you can connect
through the ODBC driver in the
connections pane you can explore the
schema of a sequel server database in
this particular case what's new in 1.2
is that you can take that work and pull
and pull those you can sort of edit the
this the sequel and manage it and run it
locally and then once you're happy with
it you can sort of extract that and pull
that into our markdown now most people
haven't seen what I don't know that our
markdown can sort of include different
kinds of code chunks and so this you
know this is what we shown you sort of
are you're now seeing sequel but now we
can also we've added more support for
Python in in the IDE so you've always
been able to add a Python code but now
you can sort of have the output of the
plots come in inline just as it would
with with our right and we've improved
the cross chunk data pass-through right
so another language we added support for
is d3 and with through the our to d3
package so now if you're really into d3
it's much easier for you to create these
types of JavaScript visualizations and
include them finally those of you made
some of you may know about Plummer which
is an open source package that you can
use to expose rest-based API endpoints
from your code right and in this
particular case we have a sentiment
analysis tool that's that is exposed
through this annotation for the predict
function and in the 1.2 release of the
IDE it's easier for you to run those
api's locally test them out make sure
that they're working the way you expect
them to and then once you're happy with
that you can go ahead and publish it to
connect just as you publish the our
markdown doc that I showed you earlier
or you can publish the shiny
applications and again we detect all the
dependencies
and those of you who you know maybe not
if we've caught that but this code is
actually using Python so not only are we
detecting the our dependencies
we're also detecting the Python
dependencies and we're going to send
those up to connect and on connect
you'll be able to sort of now it's
recreating that in that sandbox
environment and I can go ahead and try
and play with it if I want so again this
is a real model so let's try out some
things if we type in debugging I'll see
what he comes back with as a result and
not entirely surprisingly it came in a
0.149
which is not a particularly high score
now if we go up here you know we're in
Austin some people will get a chance to
do this you type in great beer we'll
come back and see a 0.88 score which is
much much better
finally let's just for yuxin giggles
type in our users amazingly enough it
comes in at 0.9 oh I swear to you we did
not play with the model this is really
what it comes back with for the Python
based sentiment analysis model all right
so just to recap our studio's goal is to
create an organization that can have a
durable contribution in this world by
creating very high quality open-source
software that is accessible to anyone
anywhere regardless of their economic
means in order to make sure that the
business would be sustainable
longer-term we decided to build a
software only business that sells
commercial versions of our open source
and server products these products help
enterprises adopt our and open source
and open science tools in production
environments the differentiation between
our open source products and our
commercial products lie in capabilities
around security authentication
monitoring tuning scaling metrics
collaboration sharing you get a
commercial license and premium support
our hope is that we can sustain this
virtuous cycle
which allows us to then invest in the
areas of the greatest needs for the art
community so far things have been going
really well
fortunately the open source packages
make are more and more accessible which
in turn drives the adoption of our and
enterprises which hopefully creates more
demand for our commercial products which
then allows us to fund even more open
source work this is it this is like it's
really really simple right put it
another way our open source products
create value for everyone and our
commercial products help businesses
leverage that value we believe that this
gives the open source community benefits
because you have talented paid open
source developers creating a growing
number of free high-quality are packages
that can be consistently maintained
commercial customers benefit from a
financially viable and sustainable
ecosystem of these open source tools and
packages along with products that meet
their enterprise IT standards for
deployment in production a thriving
ecosystem of education training and
services can bring energy new ideas and
talent to create and share data products
at a fraction of the cost and hopefully
improve our our societies and our world
thank you so much for your attention and
for taking the time to attend the
conference we are very excited to have
the opportunity to spend a few days
together I've picked out a few of the
talks that will dive into greater detail
on the topics that I could not talk very
deeply about if you are interested in
hearing more feel free to take a picture
of the slide if you want to see any live
demos or ask any deeper technical
questions please stop by our
professionals lounge if you go out the
back and towards the left there I will
you you can ask our engineers and I will
also hang out there and as an answer any
questions thank you everyone and have a
wonderful fun-filled day
[Applause]
[Music]